i appreciate you talking to me about
this show i've had so much fun with it
absolutely yes that's what i want to
hear thank you for having me thank you
i'm curious how did you come to this did
you just go through an audition process
what did you know about what it would be
because it seems like this is kind of a
big deal
yes it is and it was very much a big
deal when i got to audition for it like
you know i i
i quickly found out who was attached to
the project you know and when you see
names like steve martin martin short and
selena gomez who wouldn't want to work
with them you know and i think at the
time amy ryan was already attached as
well yeah so like all of that made for
uh
you know all the pressure in the world
for me to want to get the job you know
so uh and then you know uh here we are
now
so absolutely that's i i went through
all the
all the all the regular you know
auditions and fun stuff like that so so
how do you deal with that when you know
that like it's a really cool job and
there's these great people like how do
you go into an audition do you just
think okay i'm gonna get this do you
think there's no way i'm gonna get this
so i'm just gonna have fun with it like
how do you approach that
you know it's uh it's funny because
i mean initially
uh i think the rule of thumb uh for me
and for for many
of my um my peers that i've worked with
you know it's to always is to never
really get attached to something until
it's yours right that way
you know you gotta build the
you know thick wall you know
all the nose
and all that and all that stuff but um
remember when i when i got the uh the
appointment for the audition
um
i actually it's funny i saw this one and
i said to myself i actually told my
sister i was like
i'm gonna book this job
and she was like really she was like uh
she's like eat usually you're pretty
even killing you don't like you don't
like to get attached because you know it
could it could not go your way and i was
like yeah i was like but i can see
myself playing in this world and i want
to that's what i told her i was like i
kind of want this one bad you know i was
doing all the things that you usually
don't do you know you don't want to get
attached you don't want it you don't
want to get your hopes up but um
yeah the process was a wonderful one and
then you know when i when i got the call
it was definitely life-changing i was
crying called my parents they were
crying you know the whole the whole
thing
what was your first day on scentlink
what was the first scene you did wha
what was that experience like
i uh my first day on set
i filmed the scene where i'm going up
the steps episode one the the pilot
right so
um
my first day on set was very quick it
was very in and out i i only got to to
meet steve martin and uh
you know we had to meet uh upstairs at
the rooftop of the the building we were
shooting at uh in manhattan and um
he had the he had a face mask on and a
shield and he was like he made sure he
like
kind of yelled at me so i could hear him
he was like hi aaron he's like i'm steve
and i had the same thing on i was like
hi steve i'm aaron uh it's a pleasure to
meet you and he was like yeah usually
we'd shake hands or like you know do a
side hug he goes but you know and i was
like yeah i know so it's like you know
it was it definitely made for a
different experience at the beginning
because you know
covid and you know we had we had all the
protocols and all the safety measures
which you know we all appreciated anyway
but um
you know over time
uh you know you get to know the cast
more and everyone becomes more amicable
and you know ended up being a family at
the end but that was my that was my
first day it was it was meeting steve
under those under those conditions for
sure
this is a comedy series but it's not the
kind of comedy that has overt jokes so
how comfortable do you feel as an actor
when it comes to
comedy and humor and what did you most
enjoy about this kind of humor it's a
little bit more grounded right in truth
you would say or in every
relationally um i mean for me comedy has
been something that i've
always kind of steered away from because
it's scary it's it was always kind of
scary to me because it's it's hard i
mean if you know if we're being honest
it's it's hard to make someone laugh
yeah let alone
uh carry
you know be a part of a show or or you
know even a film so and i know that
comedy at times i've always thought of
it as very technical
um and and you know and and to be a
great comedian or to be a great comedy
actor
i feel like it's a lot of work that's
why the people that are very good and
you know people like steve martin and
martin short who are icons you know in
this in this category or actors period
you know i look at them as like
you know they're matt you're you know
you're watching a master at work so
my process was kind of just
you know being a sponge every day at
work and trying to see
the most that i could get from you know
from them both and from whoever else was
on set that day um
because i i needed to be
uh you know the biggest learner in the
room i needed to be the dumbest person
in the room essentially so
how was the experience of working with
selena gomez i mean your characters have
a history that a lot of the other
characters don't have on the show right
so what was it like to work with her to
figure that out it seems like you guys
had some fun
yeah yeah absolutely she um
she's great right off the bat i mean she
was super sweet super kind
um very very warm and inviting so
like you said because we do our
characters have such a different history
like we have history in the show
um
from the beginning and then you kind of
see it uh uh transpire into like episode
five and then you kind of see me come
into the more current
storyline right so we had to
we kind of had to build that camaraderie
offset um so you know
whether it was
running lines uh rehearsing
um
facetime calls or us hanging out and
getting to know each other as you know
like as friends so then it could
translate well on screen
um you know was was also a great
experience as well you know it was it
was super fun she was great she was she
was she was a lot of fun to work with
we learned pretty quickly that no one
can be fully trusted on this show even
if they're not actually a murderer
everybody seems to have some sort of
secret about something
so can can oscar be trusted and is there
anyone that oscar can trust
i could go as far as to say that oscar
is probably the most trustworthy person
right
but i but then i i don't know if
it's hard for oscar to trust you know
uh uh
anyone you know given the the
the hand that he's been dealt especially
at the beginning of the show we kind of
come to know what happened to oscar and
then him getting out and then seeing
kind of
you know
the stakes where they're at you know and
what's going on
for him it was definitely uh a challenge
to to trust people that's why he you
know he's kind of
uh reluctant to
to jump on board right he's he's not
really uh he's not really he's not too
uh
he's not too fond of joining the team
yet you know in in those episodes
yeah it's fun because even with him i
mean you don't really get a sense that
he's done anything but you still like
aren't sure why he was at the building
so everybody sort of has their own
thing that you know even even if they're
not a murderer they're still there's
everyone's got a little backstory yeah
everyone's
it feels a lot of times like everyone's
got their own
everyone's hiding their own like little
skeleton in the closet you know yeah
for sure you just don't want it to be
too scary in the skeleton exactly
exactly yeah
i guess
oscars yeah oscars is kind of fun yeah
yeah
in doing a murder mystery like this
how much were you trying to figure out
where the story was going and who really
did it and what was your reaction
all the time like i remember because
we got the scripts right like we we
would get one script
or two scripts bi-weekly because we we
shot in kind of a um we had block
scheduling right so we would shoot uh
two episodes
in the span of two weeks so
they really they would hold off as long
as they could with every before giving
us the next script all the time so i
would have questions about you know
episode four and five or five and six
and you know they would be like oh you
just have to wait like we're not you
know we can't tell you much yet so for
me it was it was challenging at times
because um i wanted to know what was
going to happen or i needed to know how
to kind of you know
uh keep pushing the story forward within
my character or see what choices i would
make but it also made it to where it was
super fun and fresh because you know
toward the end of the show even for us
as the actors we didn't we didn't fully
know
you know how the story was gonna kind of
end
so i mean i had a gasp moment where i
was super surprised when we read you
know the final episode i was i remember
being at the table and i was like
i was like what so hopefully uh
hopefully the audience feels feels the
same
yeah it's one of those fun things where
like i wouldn't want to
be in a situation like this where you're
trying to figure out a real murder but i
always like to figure try to figure it
out yeah me too i was always asking
questions i was always knowing my writer
i was like can you tell me more please
yeah yeah well awesome thank you so much
for talking to me about it absolutely
thank you thank you for for sharing the
space with me thank you